the Joe Rogan experience three-two-one
later today young Tim Dylan will find
out whether or not he has the antibodies
yes yes and if I do I'm going to woo Han
to do a like a fun little video in a wet
market and eat it back if I have the
antibodies it's not it's okay is it safe
I don't know what this is yeah no one
knows
we've never been in a time where
literally nobody knows I have a string
of text messages from Alex Jones yeah
like that will change your opinion if
you smoke enough weed and you don't
smoke
will you ever weed I smoked a lot of
weed for a very long time but we use
when I discovered Alex Jones 13 when I
was smoking weed listening to him on the
gcn Network but when you got clean it
wasn't we that was a problem
no it was to cocaine and booze and the
pills but weed was always there I've
never been a cocaine user I've never
used it but I do love that Buckcherry
song oh yeah it's great that's great
yeah it's a great truck
I mean don't do it if your problem Alex
left I haven't even gotten to them cuz I
got the ridge is a real I changed my
phone number not that long ago right I
change it every few months now yeah it
doesn't matter do you get random tax
from just anybody yeah rent yeah yeah
but this is these are all all these are
voicemail messages and look at all these
videos you sent me to watch and all
these websites he's convinced yeah that
it's a weaponized virus that leaked from
a lab well there's a lot of people that
are saying that in wuhan obviously they
have that lab right whether it's a bio
defense or bio research laboratory
something there something's there
something in wuhan where the disease is
somebody sent it now this is kind of
convincing that maybe there were people
set back door selling the animals that
they were experimenting on to whet
markets like if you're broke and you
were guard at the Wu Han lab you're like
hey I'm just selling bats and dogs for
extra money and he sold maybe one of the
wrong ones and now we have this issue
really where'd you hear that I mean
that's on the Internet Joe
I mean but now every theory has as much
weight as any other theory right now
right now because there's it scientists
that are actually like one of the things
they found out is that the origins of
the virus in New York City it comes
directly from Europe apparently they can
tell that interesting somehow kind of
knowing find out how they can tell they
trace it back to like patient zero the
first person so they did some sort of
tracing right because that's the new
yeah I just luck of Google and yeah
we're working together to get tracing
software see that's that's what scares
me we talked about that the other day if
you have to have everything on your
phone like showing that you're positive
yeah you know you have to have a phone
everywhere on the call you have to take
out your car that you're positive to get
into Applebee's yeah atoms antibodies
sent me this this whole thing saying
this is why I have a flip phone yeah
yeah the original father and he's saying
that he won't he won't do it
yeah most coronavirus cases in new york
city can be traced back to Europe not
Asia
research shows what is the research
though what does it say I mean research
tracking spread okra I determined the
virus has been circulating in New York
City for a couple months since before
the testing began genetic sequencing of
virus samples indicates at most the
early cases in New York originated in
Europe not Asia so it's some sort of
genetic sequencing research team studied
samples of the virus taken from 91 New
York patients as viruses evolved during
transmission from person to person their
sequences can help research this is what
scares the [ __ ] out of me just that
statement as viruses evolved yeah during
transmission these [ __ ] things they
morph and twist it sounds like it's
almost like a different thing with
different people like I was reading
about George Stephanopoulos and yes his
wife he hasn't his wife has it his wife
is deathly ill he doesn't feel a goddamn
thing that's crazy
yeah
[Applause]